since making its debut on the history
channel way back in 2010
american pickers has become one of the
most beloved shows on television airing
over 300 episodes and counting it's also
made stars of series regulars
frank fritz and mike wolf who've managed
to turn their love of digging for gold
in the backyards and broken down barns
of america into a full-blown media
empire
one that's also afforded them a pair of
cathedral-like antique stores
both of which are now legit tourist
destinations but there's at least one
antique they found that american picker
star mike wolf wishes he had held on to
and it's not what you probably think
wolfe of course is famous for his love
of bikes
whether it's vintage motorcycles or
rusted out old pedal pushers wolf has a
thing for everything two-wheeled so
you'd be forgiven for assuming that his
biggest regret
is getting rid of an old harley or huffy
you'd be forgiven
but you'd still be wrong because the
item wolf is most miffed about getting
rid of is
actually an old pair of vintage
children's cowboy boots
sounds weird but you know what they say
if the
boot fits okay
cowboy in a 2016 interview with country
living
wolf gave the whole sad backstory while
also advising
any would-be pickers to listen to that
little voice in the back of your head
when it tells you to buy something
buy it and when it tells you not to sell
something don't sell it in wolf's case
the pair of kids cowboy boots took on a
whole new significance after his wife
became pregnant with their
daughter charlie he told country living
before charlie was born i always had a
thing for vintage kids cowboy boots i
once found a pair but i sold them and
immediately regretted doing so
luckily wolfe got a second chance and he
made the most of it turning an
interest into a full-blown obsession
when jody was pregnant i found a second
pair it felt like fate so i started
collecting them
now wolfe buys vintage children's cowboy
boots every chance he gets
and once he buys them they stay with him
he showed off at least a half dozen
pairs to country living as proof of his
dedication
wolfe also shared some of his secrets to
amassing a collection like his whether
your interest
is in kids cowboy boots old bikes or
some other type of rusty gold his first
tip is simply to follow your nose and
see what you find
that run down barn over there who knows
it might have a massive pile of tiny old
cowboy boots in it or maybe it will have
just one gigantic boot instead
who knows stand it up
that's awesome wolf explained i found my
best picks by driving to the middle of
nowhere then taking the first gravel
road i see
of course there are some dangers in
approaching random houses in the middle
of nowhere
if someone's putting their boot on your
neck
you got to get used to that and for
prospective pickers hoping to spice up
their home with some vintage artifacts
wolf had another big tip don't stop at
just one buy multiples if you can they
can be really cool when done right i
like to display objects with similar
textures time periods and genres for
visual continuity
in my office each shelf has a theme
bikes motorcycles
aviation and cars it's easy to go
overboard though so i like to stick to
just one spot like mike wolfe with his
vintage bikes and his wee little boots
once you find something you're
passionate about
the thrill of the hunt and the
excitement of finding a new addition to
your collection is what makes picking so
much fun
of course while wolf no doubt will be
adding to his boot collection in the
future he and partner frank fritz were
derailed in 2020
as the coronavirus forced them to
temporarily shut down production of
american pickers
wolfe used that time to advocate for
reinvesting in local communities and to
focus on another part of his collection
buying and restoring vintage buildings
to help bring back small town main
street
these communities are important parts of
the heart and soul of america
from boots to boutiques turns out that
in the world of picking there's nothing
too big
or too small check out one of our newest
videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one